oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai décidé de passer du secteur
privé à l'humanitaire j'ai commencé par
un master en angleterre et dans le
module dans un des modules du masters il
était écrit sécurité et sûreté donc le
premier cours sur ce module le
professeur est arrivé et nous a posé des
questions la première question était
vous êtes en mission humanitaire quelle
est la première chose que vous faites
quand vous sortez de chez vous le matin
je savais pas trop et en fait c'était de
regarder sur le perron faut savoir s'il
avait pas une mine antipersonnel
la deuxième question était quelle est la
portée de balle d'un ak-47
donc moi j'arrivais clermont ferrand le
ak 47 s'était pas du tout mon quotidien
donc le ak 47 c'est une kalachnikov en
fait et donc je me disais mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ce court parce qu'en fait
ça n'a pas de sens par rapport à moi je
vais être je vais travailler dans
l'humanitaire donc je vais pas être
insolent d'or je veux pas faire la
guerre donc ça n'a aucun sens et
quelques mois plus tard j'arrivais à
kaboul
et là j'arrive et dans un aéroport avec
des forces militaires internationales
les forces militaires afghanes
des galettes nico absolument partout des
véhicules blindés et je me suis dit
peut-être que finalement ce cours a un
sens et que je vais pouvoir l'utiliser
alors pourquoi passer du privé à
l'humanitaire alors je dirais qu'à
plusieurs raisons d'abord dans le privé
je gérais des crises qui était du genre
la machine est en panne on va livrer les
clients en retard c'était une vraie
crise une catastrophe
l'imprimante industriel n'imprimait pas
la couleur que le service marketing a
émis trois jours à choisir et c est donc
en parallèle je voyais quand même les
informations puis je voyais des gens qui
mouraient qui avaient des guerres qu'ils
avaient des famines et je me disais il
ya quand même un autre monde que mes
crises d'imprimantes en fait
et puis il y avait aussi un deuxième
point qui me posait un problème c'était
la rentabilité la performance c'est à
dire qu'on était en permanence en
recherche de performance et de
rentabilité pour donner un peu de sou
actionnaires et on utilisait alors tout
ce qu'on savait relais balance scorecard
les cinq pièces etc
et puis quand je partais en vacances
avec mon fils
dans des pays étrangers on voyait par
exemple un des enfants qui étaient sur
une charrette en bois et qui attendait
en fait leur père qui était en train
d'essayer de leur trouver à manger dans
les poubelles
et là encore je me disais il ya un truc
qui va pas je pourrais peut-être faire
autre chose dans ma vie que d'essayer de
remonter de l'argent à des actionnaires
en fait
et puis à la suite de ça je suis allé
dans une école de management que vous
connaissez bien où j'ai fait un diplôme
et dans un module de rh
il y avait un module de développement
personnel on a travaillé sur nos valeurs
et donc mes valeurs elle ressortait en
étant bros l'être humain l'aide le
bonheur la joie
et puis il y avait d'autres personnes
qui étaient sur la performance la
compétition et je me suis dit mais en
fait ça ne cadre pas du tout avec mon
métier aujourd'hui d'avoir envie d'aider
des gens donc je me suis dis bah voilà
il est temps de changer de métier et je
vais faire autre chose donc j'ai fait
mon cv avec toutes mes expériences
professionnelles
j'ai envoyé dans des ong il a en fait je
me suis aperçu que les ong ne
m'attendais pas parce que j'ai reçu 0
réponse on fait donc ça a été vite total
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
décidé de faire ce master en humanitaire
où j'ai appris outre la portée de balles
d'ak-47 le fait que l'humanitaire
c'était des bénéficiaires mais c'était
aussi des donneurs qui ont des règles
extrêmement précises sur l'utilisation
des fonds ce sont des des auditeurs on à
kpmg on aère saignant qui vient à kaboul
pour auditer notre projet et nos comptes
donc la même chose que dans le privé
sauf que on est dans un pays en guerre
que on travaille aussi avec des gens qui
sont illettrés donc pour collecter tous
les documents pour les auditeurs tagnon
c'est pas tous les jours facile que
l'humanitaire c'est aussi travailler
dans des contextes politiques et
géopolitiques qui sont difficiles on à
l'armée et on a des insurgés on a des
des mafias locales des criminels et donc
tout ça ça m'a permis de voilà de ce
masters m'a permis d'apprendre ça donc
j'ai trouvé du travail derrière et je
suis parti dans plusieurs pays
le mozambique l'indonésie la côte
d'ivoire et je suis finalement arrivé en
afghanistan qui était le pays dans
lequel je rêvais d'aller depuis tout le
temps pour une raison un peu inconnu
sans doute parce que j'avais vu des
reportages
le changement c'est pas facile parce que
on passe d'une situation de confort à
une situation où on voit moins sa
famille où je voyais moins mon fils où
on travaille dans des endroits qui sont
dangereux donc la famille s'inquiète
et puis professionnellement on est à un
niveau comme ça dans le privé puis on
repasse un petit peu un niveau comme ça
pour commencer dans l'humanitaire donc
c'était pas très simple maintenant dix
ans plus tard je travaille dans une ong
je gère aujourd'hui une ong qu'à 700
personnes on a 65 centres de santé on a
deux écoles de sages-femmes deux écoles
d'infirmières on travaille sur des
projets de nutrition d'hygiène et non on
soigne à peu près cent mille patients
par mois donc je suis très contente
d'avoir fait ce changement au niveau
professionnel parce que c'est celle là
c'est une passion en fait c'est à dire
qu'on travaille dans quelque chose qui a
une passion et puis tous les jours c'est
géré avec tous les gens sympathiques
mais tous les jours ces voix là on sait
pourquoi on travaille les motivations
elles nous viennent de différentes
choses mais je dirais surtout de voir
nos bénéficiaires et de voir le résultat
je me souviens d'une ma première visite
en fait dans un nos centres de santé qui
on a des formes et des chirurgiens la
chirurgie reconstructive et on avait des
petits enfants et qu'ils avaient été
brûlés et qui n'avait plus vous allez de
nécrose et vous pouvais plus bouger de
la même façon et on travaillait avec eux
et on arrivait à faire en sorte qu'ils
retrouvent du mouvement par exemple et
ça c'était pour les fermiers pour les
enfants c'était c'était super ensuite il
ya aussi des centres de santé que nous
avons construits dans des endroits où
les gens se disaient que
j'en aurai jamais parce qu'il y avait
quasiment pas de route et qui pensaient
qu'on n'y arriverait pas et donc quand
il venait au buron ensuite pour nous
remercier avec un petit papier
d'écoliers vous avez écrit un discours
ben voila c'était des choses qui nous
donne une motivation constante
on a aussi des gens qui travaillent avec
volontairement c'est à dire en a 700
personnes mais on a aussi 1000 bénévoles
des gens qui travaillent dans l'est dans
les communautés et qui viennent aider
les communautés à avancer au niveau de
l'hygiène etc a annoncé au niveau des
dates du référencement dans les centres
de santé etc
donc ce sont des groupes qui fonctionne
ou des hommes ou des femmes à ces peaux
mixtes mais en fait chacun de leur côté
travaille sur des projets etc
c'est une des choses qui nous fait
avancer au quotidien c'est de voir leur
volonté malgré les années de guerre en
fait c'est aussi des rencontres qui sont
sympathiques g je vais prendre l'exemple
d'un mot là que j'avais rencontré qui
était à la suite d'une réunion qu'ils
aiment voir et qui me dit je sais que
vous êtes française et j'adore blaise
pascal et là il avait ce grand moment de
solitude parce que vous n'avez pas la
moindre idée de ce que vous allez lui
dire sur blaise pascal et c'est
complètement inattendu en afghanistan
donc que c'est c'est des gens qui qui
vous apprennent aussi à vous comporter
avec notre culture et à s'adapter donc
avec des tenues qui vont être un peu
différente on peut avoir août
on peut avoir des tenues standard on va
dire pour quand on les tenues de tous
les jours quand on va voir les
ministères ou cantonné dans les villes
et puis quand on rencontre des gens à un
petit peu dans lle dans les communautés
dans les campagnes où des gens comment
vous comment dire des gens qui ne sont
pas proches du gouvernement par exemple
on va s'habiller un petit peu comme ça
d'une façon différente pour pour arriver
à communiquer avec eux la difficulté de
l'humanitaire c'est de toujours trouver
de la motivation parce que il arrive ce
genre de chose par exemple on construit
des centres de santé et puis à des
combats donc les combats c'est c'est ce
que vit la population au quotidien c'est
trente ans de guerre c'est des gens de
moins de 30 ans qui n'ont jamais connu
autre chose que
que des explosions que des gens te sens
tu es que que la guerre et puis invasion
soviétique ensuite guerre civile ensuite
les talibans ensuite le temps et les
américains qui viennent avec le
gouvernement contre les taliban qui
comme si ça ne suffisait pas maintenant
il ya des chocs eyrieux donc en fait les
humanitaires en vie dans ce même
contexte
au niveau de nos projets c'est à dire
que on y va on va construire un centre
de santé et puis voilà il est dans une
zone de combat donc voilà ce qui se
passe et puis et même des choses comme
ça qui se passe c'est à dire que notre
centre de santé va être juste explosé en
fait parce que nous n'étions pas la
cible
mais la voiture était suffisamment
puissante pour avoir fait une explosion
absolument partout donc ça veut dire que
chaque fois qu'on fait quelque chose on
ne sait pas si ça va être exactement
dans la pérennité parce que ça peut
exploser le lendemain mais on continue
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des choses
positives et on se motive avec par
exemple des sages femmes qu'on va former
des infirmières donc là c'est la
cérémonie de leur diplôme de voir en
fait leur famille qui sont là et de voir
ses filles qui viennent de non droit
complètement reculées d'afghanistan qui
demain vont pouvoir soigner des gens
parce que elles sont venus dans notre
école parfois ça suffit pas des fois on
a vraiment du mal on est fatigué on a la
motivation en berne et on se dit bon on
va pas y arriver quoi on va on peut plus
alors il faut qu'on trouve des solutions
pour se ressourcer
donc ça va être un bon livre un bon
mojito 1
ça peut être aussi un bon film alors un
bon film pour moi c'est un film où tout
va bien il n'ya pas de méchants où tout
se passe bien est vraiment avec le happy
ending totale parce que des fois ça nous
manque un peu ce côté tout va bien se
passer dans l'humanitaire donc moi je
regarde des choses comme mathieu de
beaucoup de bruit pour rien qu'ils sont
voilà à tirer de shakespeare dont vous
avez la campagne verdoyante des gens qui
sont heureux
tous parlent bien et en fait vous à
regarder un pub après vous regardez déjà
in austin parce que là il ya carrément
pas de méchants du tout alors là tout va
bien aussi
et voilà et c'est ce qui vous fait dire
à bord les 1 2 3 comme ça et puis après
on repart et on se motive par rapport au
fait que les bénéficiaires y va ils
attendent quand même qu'on soit là et
qu'on essaye de les aider une des
frustrations dans l'humanitaire c'est
que on a une action très limité c'est à
dire qu'on va pas stopper la guerre on
va pas sauver tout le monde on va pas
changer le monde
donc en fait on se concentre sur ce
qu'on peut faire c'est à dire on va
jouer on va avoir par exemple un projet
avec x milliers de bénéficiaires et on
se dit bon au moins cela on en avait
quelque chose mais il faut pas vouloir
faire plus que ça parce que c'est
parfois un peu compliqué aujourd'hui la
l'humanitaire s'est professionnalisé en
fait depuis un certain nombre d'années
et on a des gens qui viennent avec des
diplômes d'ingénieur de sciences po des
écoles de management et qui cherche en
fait à un sens différent du business
pour leur vie qui ont des valeurs qui
sont un peu différentes du milieu
professionnel et qui viennent nous
rejoindre on a aussi des gens du privé
qui viennent nous rejoindre parce que
justement ils n'ont pas trop de sens
dans ce qu'il faisait et qu'ils ont
envie de trouver malades de trouver
quelque chose quelque chose d'autre on
n'est pas forcément obligé de travailler
dans des zones de guerre non plus quand
on fait humanitaire il ya des endroit
plus calme
ce que je voulais vous dire c'est que
c'est possible et que si il ya des gens
qui à qui ça parle qui ont des valeurs
un peu différente
sachez que l'humanitaire c'est très
c'est une passion on est passionné par
ce qu'on fait par le fait d'aider les
gens et puis c'est aussi très agréable
et parfois on peut faire être fier quand
on a fait quelque chose qui a qui a
fonctionné et que on a des gens qui sont
contents et qui auront une meilleure vie
grâce à nos merci
[Musique]